on est sur le pont de calix on est
arrêté voilà sept mois sans rien c'est
mois sans revenus
cette mort n'est oublié et ça fait sept
mois qu'on est fermé même sur mac row ça
fait 7 points qu'on ait oublié
vous êtes c'est du pipeau tout ce que
vous avez annoncé hier c'est juste
encore de belles promesses tout le monde
d'oublier le monde de la nuit les fidji
le spectacle tout le monde ait oublié on
en train de crever nous ça fait sept
mois qu'on attend du fric sept mois
qu'on se démerdent tout ce qu'on est
tous en train de crever 80 discothèques
sont déjà morts 300 sans difficulté
outre sa normale on n'a rien fait avec
toutes les taxes qu'on paye en
permanence on n'arrête pas de payer de
partout de partout il ya un problème on
nous laisse crever mais c'est scandaleux
bordel sourire moi vous m'avez donné les
frissons je suis entrepreneur g vous
j'ai compris votre détresse mais je
pense qu'on n'a pas besoin d'être
entrepreneur pour comprendre la détresse
ce jour là comment ça va eh ben c'est
très compliqué pour d'autres métiers
alors moi je suis entre guillemets un
peu épargné mais ça va ça va se
compliquer très rapidement parce que ça
y est mon bar et refermer ce qui me
permettait doit quand même d'avoir une
activité des revenus ce qui m'a lancé
dans le combat depuis le mois de juin
pour se faire entendre vis-à-vis de
notre gouvernement et de nos politiques
on est ça a été très très dur on a
jamais déjà l'habitude avant de faire
des vidéos pour faire des promotions des
soirées de la boîte maintenant voilà et
là maintenant la page fan de ma
discothèque est devenu carrément
peut-être un rassemblement sur toute la
france de toutes les discothèques et on
essaye de faire bouger les choses
c'est juste une question concrète vous
êtes un homme vous aviez un rythme de
vie comme beaucoup de français on vous
annonce que les boîtes de nuit sont
fermés faut déjà se réinventer vous
aviez un bar ce bar est fermé
comment vous remplissez votre frigo
juste parce qu'on sait quand on est
entrepreneur on n'a pas le chômage alors
ses douze combats de juin juillet on a
réussi à voir que monsieur grise etc est
le seul à nous écouter le ministre
on a réussi à avoir des aides mais c'est
très compliqué c'est on a beaucoup
d'effets d'annoncé qui sont qu'est-ce
qui viennent à la télé par nos
politiques et derrière en fait la vérité
tout autre la nôtre président annoncer
des choses suite au confinement
réellement ça va venir mais c'est
toujours très très long c'est long en
france et pendant ce temps là on a des
familles qui sont en train de
j'ai aujourd'hui mots on laisse crever
alors c'est pas physiquement mais là
j'ai déjà des collègues c'est les
services sociaux qui s'occupe des
enfants il ya plus d'argent
on a tous pris la boîte de nuit on n'en
parle même plus la maison la voiture
et puis non plus rien pour donner à
bouffer leurs gamins et a priori c'est
normal en 2002 en france un moment sur
le pont vous dites d'ailleurs mes
parents qui étaient commerçants s'ils me
voyait ici j'ai envie dans ce chalet
quoi ma vie privée aussi mais 2020 est
très compliqué j'ai perdu mon pop au
mois d'août
voilà donc j'ai des parents grands
parents parents commerçants mes parents
ont toujours dit que les commerçantes un
peu les vaches à lait de l'état
on nous tape dessus très souvent alors
je parle même pas des discothèques ça
n'arrête pas on a de tous les combats
l'arrêt de la cigarette le la sécurité
routière le sida on a un ami on est on
nous a demandés plein de choses on en
termes de contrôle et compagnie et à
chaque fois on fait on fait est là là
c'est le coup de grâce
enfin je veux dire on va nous aider quoi
je suis désolé je vais me faire l'avocat
du diable celui du gouvernement et je
suis vraiment de tout coeur avec vous il
ya sur les 1600 en discothèque y en a
300 qui ont déposé le bilan
mais je me dis si on avait un peu plus
de rigueur il faut qu'on tienne et qu'on
se dise on verra avec cette évaluation
d'ici une quinzaine je sais que c'est
difficile mais à choisir fin on choisit
entre la peste et le choléra c'est à
dire les difficultés financières au rip
terrible on dépose le bilan
je suis d'accord c'est la clé sous la
porte mais on meurt d'un autre côté
imaginez la proximité dans les
discothèques dans les bars dans les
boîtes de nuit donc j'entends ce cri je
le comprends je compatis mais d'un autre
côté il y a aussi cette proximité qui
fait que les gens meurent
malheureusement parce que ça on va
laisser alors c'est ce qu'on essaie
d'expliquer merci nous donne un peu la
parole ce que l'on a généralement on
arrive à avoir des petites séquences et
hélas pour le comprendre un peu olivier
v en notre mini de la santé de suite
clôturer le dossier qu'on a proposé un
protocole sanitaire pour pouvoir ouvrir
on nous expliquons un milieu confiné sq
archi faux c'est à dire qu on a des
extractions d'ailleurs qui normalement
servent pour les fumées toutes les huit
minutes l'air à ne renouveler on a
proposé un protocole sanitaire où on
enlevait la piste de danse dingue en
mettant des pistes et proposant que les
gens puissent se réservations dans ces
groupes et et surtout ce qui est
important c'est la traçabilité
c'est à dire qu'on propose que tous les
gens qui
dans la boîte seront tracées saillant on
allait coordonner ce que après les
restaurateurs ont proposé suite aux
nouvelles normes
donc en fait on a repris nos mesures là
l'autre jour j'ai eu un article la
suisse les discothèques sont ouvertes
sauf le content de genève
l'autre jour j'ai vu un article de lci
où il parlait de un club où il ya eu
quelqu'un et on le sait ça nous arrivera
aussi quelqu'un qui avait un vide donc
ils ont elles le font ils tracent 1400
personnes ont été testées et aux
quelques isolés s'il avait fait ce que
vous comprenez que c'est difficile en
attente par exemple pour les gens
aujourd'hui de voir les urgences
débordées et qui veulent juste faire la
fête par exemple en boîte de nuit
mais ce que des ati fans il est en vie
mais ça ne marche pas je suis désolé ça
ne marche pas on nous a fermé direct
déclaré coupable depuis le mois de mars
nous ne sommes pas ouverts oui vous êtes
les seuls ouvert depuis confié on a
laissé c'est un autre métier
alors j'ai le barreau si il y en a
beaucoup qui ont dysfonctionné qui n'ont
pas appliqué des protocoles sanitaires
c'était c'est quand même pour les
parisiens vous allez voir des choses
quand même incroyable et 4 passes et
voilà on a laissé faire on n'a pas si on
veut sanctionner ceux qui disent
fonctionner et surtout noble et bars se
sont retrouvés à faire notre métier et
je parle pas des restaurateurs des fois
et on en est là à cette situation
on a ici parle de parmi nous on attache
acquis également du milieu du spectacle
et donc qui à mon avis assez une pré
vraie proximité avec vous je crois que
tu voulais dire quelque chose
oui tout à fait pas déjà je comprend
forcément votre détresse c'est pas tout
à fait vrai que vous êtes les seuls à ne
pas avoir réouvert en fait par exemple
en milieu du spectacle et beaucoup de
théâtre aussi de grands théâtres qui
n'ont pas pu rouvrir parce que
l'économie leurs économies et ne permet
pas de fonctionner avec la distanciation
etc
mais il est vrai quand même que vous
êtes vraiment les oublier
de la crise et 150 vraiment bon courage
à vous voilà et c'est vrai que nos
métiers en fait sont complètement en
désaccord avec la distanciation le
confinement on est là pour créer du lien
pour réunir les gens et là je n'y a pas
vraiment de perspectives ça qui est
compliqué mais je maintiens toujours les
choses il est important un moment que le
gouvernement ont fait on nous expliquait
le président noël il va falloir se
réinventer moi je veux bien je veux bien
tout entendre mais point de ces pour se
réinventer faut nous écouter enfin déjà
et puis qu'on puisse proposer des
solutions mais on jamais et on le voit
que actuellement la politique du
gouvernement
2 on ferme on fait un pont ferme
confinement ça ne fonctionne pas c'est
fin c'est une catastrophe
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire là on
attaque un nouveau confinement un moment
on va d confiné et qu'est ce qui va se
passer on va recommencer les mêmes
erreurs et aller droit dans le mur au
moins de mars donc réellement il faut
faire travailler mieux sanctionner ceux
qui ne font pas le boulot avec des
proverbes bien sûr un protocole
sanitaires strictes
c'est faire rouvrir tout bas les bars
les restaurants la gravité des cas de
contamination était infiniment plus
faible quand on a justement dit aux gens
de rester chez eux et c'est à partir du
moment où ils ce sont des confits n'est
que là il revient d'avoir cette
explosion mais non c'était bien de
virements excuse moi je peux pas laisser
dire ça parce que c'est particulièrement
injuste pour les boîtes de nuit moi je
vous soutiens à 1000% je vous expliquer
pourquoi
parce que moi je suis dans le sud cet
été je suis allé à saint tropez chez al
akkad toutes les boîtes étaient fermés
c'était c'est injuste pourquoi parce que
tu coûtes tous les restaurants se sont
transformés en boîte de nuit j y étais
donc je peux en témoigner je le
reconnais je l assume je l avoue j étais
de bois deux étaient des boîtes de nuit
mais ambulante cts était incontestable
et là j'ai discuté avec un patron de
boîte de nuit qui était au bord de
l'agonie financière c'était un drame
parce qu'ils rentrent en dépression au
bord du suicide
donc c'est aussi grave excuse moi q que
la maladie d'accord parce qu'à des gens
qui se suicident aujourd'hui de la perte
de leur entreprise la mairie santé
mentale
s'il vous plaît excuse moi et qui voit
en face dans la rue un restaurant tu
fait leur travail avec des gentils dans
ce poème pelops je les fais sans masques
sont rien personne ne leur dit rien
pourquoi cette injustice et je perds
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui les boîtes se
révoltent parce que quand ils ont
réouvert cet été après le confinement
ils ont laissé les restaurants faire dé
devenir des boîtes de nuit mais par
contre toi tu sais boîte de nuit n'ont
pas tu crèves et puis toi tu vis
normalement on évite un truc concret à
monsieur puisque on a parlé quand même
jeunes est de 15000 euros qui pourrait
être prolongé jusqu'à fin décembre je
sais que vous êtes vous attendez un
décret pour que cette aide soit plus
accessible et loire et nuits est employé
à calmer mais il ya également quand même
d'aider des gérants de boîtes de nuit
qui demandent actuellement carrément à
l'état de clairement rembourser leur
fond de commerce est ce que c'est une
démarche que vous envisagez alors oui
effectivement il ya plusieurs de mes
collègues qui demande que l'état en fait
nous rachète nos fonds de commerce mais
il trouve l'argent ou à un moment l'état
l'a réellement c'est de la folie mais
pour les propriétaires du fonds et des
murs à la rigueur je peux peut-être
encore l'entendre mois exemple rien
lâché à un propriétaire de mes murs ça
veut dire que l'état me rachèterait mon
fond et en plus signerait un bail avec
mon propriétaire ça me semble un peu
compliqué à tenir
marzio lequel justement moi je pensais
je ne sais pas si c'est encore si ces
effectifs ou pas où ça peut l'être
monsieur ma peau notre président plus
sérieusement c'est est ce que vous êtes
exonérés c'est bête mais de taxes
foncières de taxe d'habitation de taxes
tout court et je m'adresse là pour les
commerçants les personnes du spectacle
les gens qui perdent leur emploi à des
reports mais il n'ya pas l'annulation de
la dette cumulée sur l'élan est en fait
c'est ça qui est difficile aujourd'hui
c'est ce que ce qu'on se disait aussi
c'est que oui c'est reporté oui c'est
reporté mais pour nourrir finalement
parce que quand les gens vont devoir
faire face à toutes ses responsabilités
et les bailleurs contrairement à ce
qu'on dit exigent le paiement de leur
loyer parce qu'ils ont aussi eu leur
échéance eh bien on arrivera à une
situation de chaos
oui aujourd'hui vous avez un message e
extrêmement humain extrêmement fort pour
tous vos collègues qui sont justement
dans cette difficulté et c'est ce que
vous criez vous étiez en train de crier
sur le pont je la sais pas je le répète
on est je suis pas médecin s'est pas
fait les études je suis pas politique
non plus je suis juste patron de boîte
de nuit normalement je suis là plutôt
pour amuser les gens qui passent une
bonne soirée
mais malgré tout on a des choses à
proposer au gouvernement je pense que la
politique actuelle et je le dis et je le
répète de tout fermer est une erreur
alors maintenant c'est trop tard
effectivement la ffo confiné mais au
déconfinement va faire travailler avec
les vrais professionnels ce qui
normalement c'est notre métier de faire
danser travailler avec nous les
restaurants restent des restaurants les
bars et ce débat et ça marchera très bon
ministre